hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that takes the fine art of
entertainment and makes it competitive
usually it's just for fun but today
we're going for blood because it's a
macabre movie mashup that will pit two
styles of horror movies against each
other it's slasher films taking on
ghostflix right now on verses
you may hear that and exclaim mark you
gorgeous sob you've actually compiled
the stats and crunched the numbers on
every slasher and ghost movie ever what
an absolute stud you are well that may
be true but no no no no that would have
taken way too long and made me really
tired and when i fall asleep there's
this guy on elm street that shows up and
really puts a debt in my rem cycle so
instead we here at rotten tomatoes
debated deliberated deduced and derived
by films from each team to represent
their side in glorious battle they may
not be the best they're certainly not
the worst and if they're not your picks
just remember you don't pay me to host
however i do have a venmo in which all
proceeds go defeating a sweet dog that
protects me from things that go bump in
the night poppy will be home soon maui
alright let's take a look at each team's
starting lineup representing slasher
movies it's halloween a nightmare on elm
street candy man scream and happy death
day i love how much i sound like the old
movie phone guy and now the starting
lineup for your chicago bull i mean
ghost movies the shining the sixth sense
the devil's backbone the ring and number
23 from north carolina it's the
conjuring i'll now pause a moment so
that you can scream not in tear but in
utter shock about whatever movie you
feel should have made the cut texas
chainsaw massacre the others you're next
heck my own producer won't even talk to
me because the exorcist isn't here i'm
sorry but i feel that in addition to
being the scariest movie ever made the
exorcist is more of a possession film
than a ghost movie
although one could argue that conjuring
is kind of in line with demons and
candyman is a slasher but it goes too
look the venn diagram for these two
subsets overlaps quite a bit so we're
just having a good time here celebrating
some of the best horror films of all
time and if you have any more issues
with our cinematic selections simply
turn out all the lights in your house
look in the mirror and say my social
media handle three times nothing's gonna
happen but you'll feel better here's how
we'll determine a winner round one box
office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three i'm ready for
my close-up round four bloody good show
and then we'll do a wild card round that
freddy krueger hopes involves an open
mic night because he would crush the
hardest welcome to prime time it's
slasher movies in which a medicine
killer is on the loose with an
unquenchable thirst for blood taking on
ghost films in which a menacing spirit
is on the loose with an insatiable
appetite for destruction paradise city
is miles away and be warned sweet
children know mine welcome to the jungle
let's get it on round one box office if
there's one thing that slashers and
ghosts can agree on it's that money
can't buy happiness however it can
encourage studios to make sequels to
your movies which means more
opportunities for death and destruction
so out of our 10 films in competition
here today which one stands severed head
and shoulders above the rest halloween
did pretty well back in 1978 scream done
very good in the summer of 96 but it's
1999's the sixth sense that annihilates
its nearest competition by over 300
million dollars and night shyamalan's
feature film crushed at the domestic box
office to the tune of 540 million
dollars which gives ghostflix a big
early lead however scream is next on the
coin list with its 209 million dollar
take and the ring's 203 million dollar
bow make them the only other films to
top 200 million dollars here in the
states michael myers debut got oh so
close with and adjusted for inflation
188 million take so we got us a good
ball game and considering that the
devil's backbone doesn't have reliable
box office data the rest of the ghost
movies better not attempt to coast on
dead bruce willis's wings oh come on
it's been out for like two decades you
had your chance to see it good news for
the afterlife contingent is that the
ring is a very frightening remake of a
japanese horror classic and we lined up
in droves to cheer samara out of that
well the shining and the conjuring also
creeped us out on mass as both flicks
topped the 150 million domestic mark
which means even if we pretend not one
soul saw the devil's backbone on any
sort of regulated projection device
ghost movies would still boast an
average reaping of over 200 million
bucks slashers y'all are backed into a
corner which may not have been the
wisest move on my part freddie's upset
and candyman is dismayed not necessarily
at me because again i'm just the
messenger fellas but at their total box
office numbers while the og nightmare
did a respectable 70 million dollars on
its run and the candy guy adds in 56
million bucks they just can't compete
with jack nicholson and a typewriter
happy death day was a surprise success
that spawned a cute little franchise but
it initially only notched 57 million
dollars when released in theaters the
groundhog saw its own shadow overall
slashers still come out with their ego
intact as their domestic box office
average is 116 million dollars per
outing however even without the sixth
sense blockbuster power ghost movies
would still edge out its nemesis today
and including the sixth sense well let's
just say that hayley joel osment can
finally sleep soundly his sub genre wins
the round and ghost movies take a one to
nothing lead
round two tomato meter slash audience
score ghosts and slashers and slasher
ghosts and ghosts who derived from
slashers love wreaking havoc upon the
unsuspecting masses but in round two
it's them who run the risk of being
victimized at the hands of critics and
audiences who took in their adventures
horror movies are generally crowd
pleasers and there's nothing like seeing
a scary movie in the theater opening
weekend especially if you got your
tickets on the fandango app just waiting
for my notification to appear and there
it is employee of the month again how do
i do it i don't know i just do it so
let's start happy and see how ghost and
slasher movies did in terms of making
the patrons satisfied on the audience
score metric um y'all both did really
well if any of the teenagers in those
films survived they could get into a
reputable university with these grades
ghost movies average 80.6 percent on the
audience score and slashers team up to
earn 76
bravo the shining leads the entire pack
with 93
and while stephen king may not be one of
those votes he famously wasn't a fan of
what kubrick did with his source
material it does set the pace for its
ghoulish teammates as the sixth sense
clocks in at 90
and the devil's backbone hits 89 percent
meanwhile on team slash it's halloween
that blazes the trail forward at 89
percent on the audience score with a
nightmare on elm street mirroring its
release date year at 84 percent screams
at 79 and both candyman and happy death
day are in the 60s which means all five
slasher films are fresh on this metric
the same cannot be said for ghost movies
the conjuring is safe at 83 percent but
the ring fell curiously all the way down
to 48
what gives was it the fact that it was a
remake does a creepy lady combing her
hair bore you you don't like lighthouses
come on what gives sorry sorry i yelled
you're not gonna judge our final list of
movies i won't judge your taste in said
flicks but the ring's a good movie so we
got a tight ball game so far in this
round and now we venture over to the
measurement that has doomed many a
horror film and cast it into hell for
all eternity the tomato meter and guess
what we're actually fresh all of us
every one of our 10 movies is fresh on
the tomato meter you get a tomato and
you get a tomato the ripest of all of
our veggies are awarded to lumbering
psychopath michael myers whose halloween
scared up a game high 96 percent fresh
with his pal freddy and the first
nightmare notching 94 percent as for
jason voorhees uh he could make it today
he had swim practice guillermo del
toro's the devil's backbone is the
clubhouse leader for team ghost as it's
the only flick on the team in the 90s at
92 percent no film on either list falls
even to the 60s on the tomato meter even
you the ring however it is that darn vhs
tape movie that's the lowest rated here
too sporting a 71 percent since sequels
are fun and trilogies are funner and
tens of movies are the funnest those
aren't real words children don't use
them of the film franchises represent
here that have at least three entries in
them scream is the only one to maintain
a fresh average at 65
for the entire property it's a good
thing they made that fourth one too
let's go for five all told the film sets
tie on the tomato meter with twin
averages of 83.6 percent and despite
ghost movies edging out slashers on the
audience score it's consistency that
will win the day in this round and since
none of those stabby movies fall below
fresh on the tomato meter or the
audience score i'm awarding them this
round and because i feel bad i made fun
of jason can we send flowers to jason's
mom
no she's
all right i guess it's tied up and we're
going to round three at one to one round
three i'm ready for my close-up that's
what the stars say when they're looking
their best and prepared to be front and
center which is exactly where our gaggle
of villains feel mostly at home even if
they're haunting from a hotel this round
will be won by which team has the better
roster of villains we're sporting
everything from evil spirits to the
undead to those peanut butter and jelly
college roommates but of course you
gotta kick off with the headliner
performing at the punxsutawney funny
bone this friday and saturday one show
only freddy krueger
and while freddie's career in the
nightmare and um street film saw him
matriculate in both creative murders and
witty one-liners ferd wasn't as quippy
in the original probably because that
whole parents burned me alive and it's
murky if i ever actually committed a
crime thing was still fresh in his mind
i stand by my belief that janitor
krueger was a child murderer and
deserved to be killed by an angry mob
who had no idea the nightmare that act
would conjure years later freddie he's
got it all he's burned beyond belief
before deadpool made it fashionable he's
got a recognizable home team uniform and
the glove ooh the glove of knives is so
versatile this
[Music]
is god it can stab a snoozing freshman
it can help suck a young johnny depp
into his bed but you can also simply
scratch a surface to provide a menacing
preamble of the carnage to come freddie
does enough talking for his entire
slasher team and that's the good news
because michael myers and candyman
they're not as big on words they let
their actions do the talking
specifically their intrusive sudden
appearances on either halloween nights
or when rambunctious kids attempt to
summon them in the mirror they both have
achieved icon status thanks to the
mythology behind their characters
candyman hails from centuries of
suffering and michael myers well he's
known simply as the shape for a reason
it's hard to stop a shape it just keeps
showing up and just when you think
you've killed it the fire department
comes and puts the flames out let him
burn i cheated as that's from halloween
kills the sequel to the second reboot of
the franchise and the i don't know what
is it the 38th film in the series
overall the conjuring also has a ton of
flicks in its lore but originally it was
a presence named bathsheba that we're
all concerned about we're going to get
to you valik just wait creepy nun
bashiba who i still contend was a friend
of the warrens and ran this con haunted
house operation with them for years does
more than enough as a frightening
ghostly presence this ghoul demon
whatever nomenclature you prefer this
spirit can be playful menacing and
downright violent all in the same scene
but sometimes we need to get an up-close
look at what's haunting us and luckily
we have samara from the ring she didn't
have a great life and now she's trapped
in a well but she enjoys climbing out of
it if you watch her home movie the slow
crawl the unnatural movements the fact
that she's still a kid it all adds up to
a super scary entity that we as an
audience might hide our eyes during said
close-up don't be a hero moviegoer be
like me it's okay to keep them lid shut
to preserve a good night's sleep good
luck getting them z's with jacinto down
the block the ghostly force in the
devil's backbone is the perfect
embodiment of a theme you'll see in many
del toro flicks spectres are terrifying
but they're more a reflection of how
humanity can be the real horror show
jacinto gets a ton of screen time and
that was done on purpose to desensitize
us to his frightening appearance forcing
us to look inward to the real evil just
be nicer to one another people and maybe
take some time to play because if it's
just work jack is not only a dull boy
he's a lunatic that gets all axe wieldy
the shinings overlook hotel turns the
batman 89 joker into a villain even a
slasher by the end of the movie so if
you're gonna ask shelley duvall she'd
tell you that's the primary bad guy in
the movie but from what we know about
this overall property something less
seen and more hellacious is lurking
below the surface and for all the ghost
bartenders and creepy twins of the
shining for me the primary villain is
still the prom queen who is taking a
bath in room 237 folks i stay in hotels
all the time and i'm happy to crash on a
13th floor or even room 1408 but room
237
never have never will i do believe that
sometimes ghosts can help and we get
hints of that in the devil's backbone
and certainly in the sixth sense where a
new kid on the block hangs tough as the
biggest villain but slasher movies leave
no doubt as to who is the baddie and
sometimes they combine the perfect blend
of athleticism and trash talk lumbering
forces though they may be folks like
myers and candyman don't move or speak
like ghostface who might be a little too
fast for his own good for every quick
cut there's also a trip or a fall or a
tow stub but that voice modulation
thingy its usage is practical as we have
no idea who the real killer behind the
mask is and it's also a truly terrifying
growl ghostface and lori spengler who is
not related to egon but is the negative
nelly roommate and happy death day
proved that sometimes the scariest
threats of all are the ones closest to
home they're the folks that we trusted
to be in our lives and sometimes there
are boyfriends who we like get to third
base thank you nev campbell for drawing
the line at a pg-13 relationship with
billy because him and his zany pal stew
they're actually deranged murderers
ghosts have to work harder to win us
over and maybe we'll realize that
they're just trying to help of course
that's not the case with all of them
samara bashiba
nuns but with slashers there is no gray
area and there's no greater good being
served even if your motivation is
understandable like with candyman or
freddy krueger's past it's still clear
who the antagonist is them
slasher films prove that us humans can
rarely be trusted and when we cross over
to a realm that gives our most evil
people supernatural powers they become
legends freddie michael myers ghostface
candyman these are household names for a
reason when ghosts prefer hiding and
making the occasional
sound to freak us out slashers are
always ready for their close-up and thus
they win this round showcasing the best
villains and now the slashers have the
lead 2-1 round four bloody good show
that's british speak for the good old
horrific moments that have become iconic
you don't get to be a popular fresh
talked about on the hit show versus
unless you're chock full of memorable
sequences that scared delighted and made
us jump in our seats although truth be
told when i'm watching one of these
movies at home just me and the dog the
lights out i'm usually pacing back and
forth like a football coach trying to
hold it together
no challenge fights will be thrown in
this round it's the best of the best in
terms of moments here's johnny well
actually that's beloved actor jack
nicholson completely freaking out after
being stuck in a haunted hotel for
months on end and this line that jack
reportedly improvised on set is so
famous it made it into the afi's top 100
movie quotes list it's almost as good as
yoo-hoo i'll make you famous was it
young gun stew isn't on that list
blasphemy but the shining is far from a
one moment wonder it's arguably the most
famous ghost movie because start to
finish it rocks the viewer to the core
with horrific imagery like an elevator
full of blood someone in the jacuzzi and
worst of all creepy twins stanley
kubrick's use of steadicam shots further
unnerve us innocent gawkers especially
those who travel frequently i'm telling
you every time i'm awake in a hotel past
midnight i think about this damn movie
it makes an empty bar a dinner room a
long hallway the most terrifying thing
imaginable but now i actually want to go
root for some kids so let's get on board
with santi from the devil's backbone and
cole from the sixth sense both see
things they'd rather not frequently in
the form of spirits that they
understandably shy away from guillermo
del toro's wide shots force us into
asking if we're really seeing that
spirit and m night's indelible twists
answer questions we didn't even know
that we were going to ask most folks
remember the line i see dead people but
for me it's the following sentences that
are even more chilling when a tough guy
like john mcclane is processing some
rando kid saying that when we feel the
hairs on the back of our necks stick up
that's them
me in the theater hearing that line it
made my neck hair stand up was that a
ghost probably they never cleaned that
movie theater if it's slasher movies you
love then it's probably cinematic kills
you crave freddy's pretty darn good at
it and his knife glove is merely the
opening act the suck is cool the blood
spewing after is the icing on a very
gross cake the spinning room sequence is
just as inventive and the glove coming
out of the bathtub as nancy does her
best to stay awake is one for the ages
and let's give a shout out to heather
wagonkamp's lead character she goes toe
to toe with krueger and doesn't bat an
eye if only her dad john saxon believed
her earlier the first appearance of
candy man is every horror fan's dream or
a nightmare scenario because it's so
exciting when a new iconic baddie
emerges on the scene and if you had any
doubts as to whether tony todd would be
a formidable foe witness the excessive
amount of blood spewing when he off poor
bernadette and as far as memorable
murders go ghostface has a few on its
resume as well kicking off with
america's extraterrestrial befriending
sweetheart drew barrymore drew was
originally set to play the lead role of
sydney prescott but five weeks before
shooting switched to play casey the
jiffy pop spokesperson who gets gutted
in the opening sequence both her and
director wes craven agreed that this
would throw the audience for a loop
right out of the gate and it would keep
us guessing right until the end but for
me the best parts of scream are the nods
to the horror genre itself jamie
kennedy's video store cinephile randy
explaining the rules of scary movies to
his pals and us the audience was the
perfect refresher course and ghost
facers stu and billy play their part so
well that we really didn't have any idea
who was under that mask we did know who
was in the well in the ring and it was
just a wee little tyke but her slow
crawl out towards the screen and through
the tv was just as menacing and a little
faster paced than anything michael myers
has ever done i love the static images
of meyers staring up through a window
amidst a clothesline and john
carpenter's halloween score is its own
level of iconic but something about gore
burbinski's pace and use of space make
us feel like we're never out of reach
from samara's frightening grasp his
direction and naomi watts's excellent
performance put the ring on a par with
its japanese inspiration ringu this is
really a tough round to call but if it's
close now and we haven't even touched on
happy death day or the conjuring i like
team ghost odds i love when tree finally
gets john toombs after a day so long
only bill murray could relate to it but
the conjuring achieved a feat rarely
seen in any genre like the shining it
felt like one long iconic moment from
the moment lorraine sees a spirit james
juan proves that he's much more than a
jump-scare master his frights get into
our very soul the climactic sequence is
a literal kitchen think throw of
everything we've ever feared about
devilish schools in the afterlife and
the clap scene was the perfect way to
tease audiences in the conjuring trailer
i sent that youtube link to my sister as
soon as it came out and we were both on
the same page sleeping with one eye open
that night and we need to get to a
theater opening night for this one
slasher flicks have a lot to hang their
dirty brown hats on in this round they
feature some of the most recognizable
characters not just in horror mythology
but in all of cinematic history but when
it comes to the actual moments that make
us jump shriek and stay with us long
after the theater lights come back on
there's nothing like a good ghost movie
and the five representing that team here
must around a win in round four the
match is once again tied it's two to two
oh my god this is a nightmare and now
it's time for the wild card round
i wanted to name this round after the
noise that we all make if we get truly
scared but the problem is we all have
our own individual methods of expressing
our concern what's yours most people
like the ah i prefer the oh geez am i
producer well she's still mad about the
exorcist exclusion did anyone ever
consider the fact that maybe i didn't
want to watch the exorcist again because
it scares me and i go oh geez every
eight seconds and now they put in that
crab walk and the extended cut i can't
get it out of my head captain howdy give
me peace
this round won't be quite as simple as
which of these 10 movies scare me the
most i'm also gonna open up the playing
field to include some notable highlights
of other films found inside these
franchises it's one thing to make me
lose sleep for a few nights it's a
higher level of ability if you can
frighten the crap out of me and make me
want to see your sequel and that sequel
and then probably a reboot at some point
if a movie franchise like scream loses
some points for not being as scary as it
is overall entertaining then it earns
them all right back by being a solid
franchise yes even you scream three i
love the movie theater opening of stab
in scream 2 and the cast reunion for
part 4 but screen 3 arguably gives me
the most chills just check out the scene
where sydney sees her mom that's classic
horror movie stuff right there candyman
2 had some good chills and that recent
reboot it bit off a lot chewed most of
it rather successfully as a nightmare in
elm street films progressed it did seem
like freddy was just as concerned with
making us all laugh with zany henny
youngman one-liners as he was actually
killing kids but nightmare on elm street
3
more on that in a minute ghost movies
hooked me simply because none of us are
really sure what lies in store for us in
the great beyond unless you're a 900
year old muppet named yoda could we be
doomed to roam the grounds like in the
devil's backbone or the shining will we
take a special beetlejuice-like glee and
terrifying future homeowners like in the
conjuring will we even know if we're
dead or will it be like you know what
the guy was dead in the sixth sense
sorry spoilers it's been out 20 years
the shining showed great promise and
while i enjoyed the tv film starring
wings legend stephen weber it wasn't
until dr sleep came along that i said
wow we got a ton of potential for more
stories here and let's not forget the
crossover appeal of a truly scary horror
segment the shining was quite possibly
the best part of steven spielberg's
futuristic sci-fi romp ready player one
it brought back all the chills the ring
struggled to find its footing with both
the sequel and the reboot and the sixth
sense maybe it's left better as a
standalone thriller but don't worry
those tricky warrens they have boatloads
of yarns to spin i even dug the original
annabelle loved her prequel and got
super into the conjuring too for many
reasons not the least of which
is the none
alright so let's talk about it the nun
is a movie in that universe and it's
particularly chilling for a kid who
spent years in catholic school her evil
phase the habit this is one penguin
whose story you do not want morgan
freeman narrating but as scary as that
nun is let's get back to nightmare in
elm street 3. it's my favorite in a
whole bunch and not just because dawkin
rocked on the soundtrack there's a
creepy nun here too and she keeps
showing up in the distance in an
all-white habit staring daggers at us
well it turns out she's a ghost nun and
she's wearing the nuns away uniform
she's playing a road game but she's
actually helping us as it turns out
she's warning the good folks about her
son freddie yep that's amanda krueger
freddy's mom and i don't care if she's
good bad alive dead indifferent stop
showing up at the foot of my bed i'm
happy being single you weirdo back off
and if i was ruling strictly on
franchise ability i would have to side
with slasher movies despite the massive
box box-office success of the conjuring
flicks slashers just take a simple
formula and can churn out hit after hit
after hit because we have a now famous
killer on the poster returning once
again to terrorize predominantly naked
teenagers who lost their virginity too
early but in doing so some of that scare
value gets lost with each subsequent
outing for every nightmare in elm street
3 there's a curse of michael myers that
offers little more than an excuse to
munch on extra buttery popcorn ghost
movies are much more terrifying to me
because there's no way to stop them or
even realize that they're attacking us
until it's too late maybe it's our own
fault because we watch the videotape or
they need our assistance or they're just
[ __ ] who like to slam cabinets but
regardless of motive they're scary
because they can show up in any form
whenever they please like randy dishing
out the horror movie rules slasher films
do abide by a more structured code if
you want to avoid ghostface keep it
pg-13 in the bedroom you want to stay
away from freddy boil a pot of coffee
hoping to avoid candyman um here's an
idea don't summon him some slashers are
mere human beings and it sucks that we
turn on our own species like that but at
least we can lock them out or fight back
or run up the stairs no no wait don't
run up the stairs never run up the
stairs in a slasher movie now if it's a
ghost movie we're screwed and we
probably have to call a member of the
clergy
which means a nun could be coming to the
house along with an evil spirit god i
hope she's not wearing that all-white
habit
the scariest wild card round in versus
history goes to ghost movies and that's
the team that narrowly defeats team
slasher in this match three to two
now you gotta die
those are the rules my dear apologies to
my fellow stand-up comic freddie in case
you were wondering what my favorite
one-liner is it's in freddy's dead the
final nightmare or nightmare in elm
street part six by now we were turning
teens into video games to kill them and
fred exclaims after doing just that now
i'm playing with power and his glove was
a nintendo power glove and if you think
that jumped the shark remember this the
actual guy who jumped the shark where
that phrase comes from that was the fonz
on happy days possibly the coolest human
in history and he'd go on to play the
principal in scream freddy is the fonz
of horror movies swagger humor signature
attire an air of mystery you keep being
you you handsome janitor bastard and now
it's your turn my lovely viewers which
subgenre do you prefer
and the social media floodgates are now
open at mark ellis live for you to
scream about which movies should have
made our esteemed list paranormal
activity friday the 13th the exorcist
how about pet cemetery church the cat is
a pretty badass ghost ah well there's
always next halloween until then i'm
mark ellis thanks for watching verses
and in the immortal words of a famous
school custodian no running in the
hallway
[Music]
you